senator john tester is the farmer who
went to washington
while growing up in montana he dreamt of
a career in music
but his life was changed by an early
tragedy tester took over the family
business and eventually entered politics
where he's currently serving his third
term
in the u.s senate he has picked some
pretty big fights in dc along the way
and in his new book grounded he has a
message
for both parties here we go
nice oh that looked good yeah it did it
was nice
we don't know many senators who would
agree to play a game of pig with us on a
backyard basketball court
backboard there it is but john tester
isn't like most senators oh yes the
bottom line is is that the farm is
really who i
am tester grew up in big sandy montana
with parents who worked the land and
butchered
tester loved sports and music but he
also wanted to help as he writes and
grounded
his early eagerness changed the course
of his life
at the age of just nine can i see your
hand
what happened it's uh
you never get in fight with power
equipment because power criminal always
wins
tester's left hand was torn apart he
lost
three fingers in a meat grinder and to
this day
deals with spiking pain when he knocks
it the wrong way to be honest with you i
cannot remember sticking my hand
in the throat of that grinder i remember
pulling my hand out
i think it hypnotized me the way you
talk about what happened in the book
even more than 50 years later is very
graphic and very emotional yeah
you know i i did the audio before
portion of this book
and and i know the people who ran the
audio studio studio were
were shaking their head at me because i
had a real hard time talking about it
um it brought tears to my eyes and i got
choked up and i have to start over and
re-record and re-record
and it's because i'm a lot older now and
and as a kid i looked at it from a kid's
perspective and you know kids
they're rough and tumble they rock and
roll they easily adapt
when you get to be a parent and you
think about what my folks went through
it had to be really really really hard
especially for my mother who was there
and you don't think you'd be a senator
today
if that hadn't happened it would have
certainly changed my life who knows
i might have you know i've got a
bachelor of science in music i might
have went into music and
played saxophone instead of trumpet and
ended up
in new york city with some dog on jazz
band who knows you know
the truth is you just don't know where
life's going to take you and
it made me a little different tester's
one time dream of playing music
professionally may have ended but he
still went on to teach
music while also reffing high school
basketball
and running the farm 25 years ago he
felt a political itch
and rose from the ranks of local school
board to state legislature
to eventually being elected as a
democratic u.s senator
in 2006. the book opens with his biggest
national moment so far
in 2018 he released damaging information
about ronnie jackson
the president's nominee to run the
department of veterans affairs
jackson's nomination was pulled
president trump called on tester
to resign did you regret that that
process had to get so ugly
well of course i would much rather not
and we tried to uh through the people
that we knew in the white house to try
to
to bring some common sense to the
situation
but in the end veterans are my foremost
obligation and much higher obligation of
them than to the president
so i'm going to do what's right by them
the book is called grounded
and it's your your outreach to
rural communities in this country
particularly how democrats can reach out
to rural communities and reconnect why
do you think they've lost some of those
communities
i think a lot of it has been the fact
that we haven't shown up and when we
have showed up we haven't expressed what
we stand for very well
and i think if you look at the values
that democrats have and
and what we really stand up for uh good
education
good health care medicare social
security making sure our veterans are
taken care of make sure we got good
infrastructure
those are all things that democrats
stand for i saw a headline the other day
calling montana a deep red state
it's really not based on the way people
have voted
you're right it's just 20 years or so
it's a deep libertarian state
[Laughter]
truth is you've got democrats
republicans and they're all libertarians
chester has won re-election twice in a
state where hillary clinton received
less than 36 percent of the vote in
2016.
he's made hay railing against the
influence of lobbying money
though he acknowledges he's taken plenty
of it himself especially following the
controversial 2010 supreme court
decision
citizens united versus fec when it comes
to lobbying money too
a lot more lobbying money for you and
for everybody else yeah
after citizens yeah and i think it's one
of the reasons we have the division in
our country right now politically
but the argument is free speech it's
free speech well i i i
money and free speech i i don't get it
we're sitting here talking and
and we can grab a mic and my neighbor
can grab a mic or get on the radio
if i got 10 million dollars i got a lot
more free speech than you got
i don't i know the supreme court made
the decision but i don't agree with that
connection tester's commute is extreme
4 000 miles round trip every week via
car and planes
so he never spends too much time away
from his family
and the farm look i had many people tell
me when i said i'm going to keep farming
and i'm going to go home every weekend
said you'll never last you won't last a
year we've been doing it now for nearly
14 years
you talk in the book as well about some
of the senators who you learned from
when you first started
who had been there for a long long time
including senator mikulski senator byrd
others do you still want to be in the
senate when you're
85 or 90 no no i don't
look i love the senate it's great i get
to work with great people in the state i
get to work with great people
on both sides of the aisle in the senate
but it ain't the best job i ever had
uh being a farmer is the best job i ever
had
wow and you believe him when he said it
too absolutely
i mean we get up at two or three o'clock
in the morning to come in here right he
gets up at two or three o'clock in the
morning on monday
to drive an hour or two to an airport
take two flights
get into washington spend a few days
there and then come back every weekend
devotion yep there it is